In the previous lesson, we learned some tricks we can employ as operating
system designers for optimizing the RPC communication
software which powers client-server communication in the
local area network from the point of
view of reducing communication latency. Of course,
user interactions go beyond the local area
network to the wide area Internet. The
primary issue, once a packet leaves your
local node, is to route the packet reliably
and quickly to the destination. Routing is part
of the functionality of the network layer of
the protocol stack of an operating system.
What happens to a packet once it leaves
your node? Well, the intermediate hardware routers between
your node and the destination have routing tables.
That help them to move the packet towards the
desired destination node by doing a table look-up. The
routing tables evolve over time, since the Internet itself
is evolving continually. That's the big picture. And there are
lots of fascinating details which you can learn in
a course that is dedicated to computer networking. For
the next part of the lesson on distributed systems,
we want to ask the question, what can be done
in the intermediate routers, to accommodate the quality
of service needs of individual packet flows through
the network? Or in other words, can we
make the routers en route to the destinations smart?
The specific thought experiment we are going to
discuss is called active networks. And then, we
will connect the dots from active networks to
the current state of the art, which is referred
to as software defined networking. Thus far
in the course, we've been focusing on
specializing operating system services for a single
processor, or a multi-core or a parallel system,
or a local area network. In this lesson, we will take this idea of specializing
to the the wide area network. Specifically, we will study the idea of providing
quality of service for network communication in
an operating system by making the network active.